Chicken Little was one of the first CG
anime films that Disney did without
Pixar's help and boy does it show this
is a film that tries all sorts of
different visual humor and verbal humor
and technical humor all sorts of
different kinds of humor and very few of
them ever hit the mark I'm I refer it's
ambition but man when this film misses
it really misses right down to the
premise which hey maybe we should take a
look at in the neighborhood filled with
walking talking animals Chicken Little
swears he sees something in the sky
this guy itself apparently falling but
when they discover it's just a mistake
Chicken Little is humiliated along with
his father who constantly tries to
distance himself from his son despite
the fact that the son only wants his
respect and love
I'll cast it he finds another group of
friends that also don't seem to be very
popular runt of the litter the ugly
duckling and fish out of water
yes that's literally their names and hey
hey I think it's kind of funny despite
the fact that everybody thinks he's a
loser including his father Chicken
Little tries out for the baseball team
that actually Maja's to win a game
suddenly he's the town hero a once again
has his father's attention but that may
all change when he discovers an alien
attack mutant creatures from outer space
apparently are infiltrating Earth's
atmosphere by disguising themselves what
else as the sky Chicken Little of course
comes across it but it's afraid to let
anybody know because it might ruin his
popularity will he do the right thing
and yet somehow win his father's love in
the end does this movie try way too hard
way too often the answer to both is yes
on the one hand I admire the film for
how much it's throwing at us I mean to
begin with this is a weird premise
obviously it's based on the fable but to
turn into an everyday modern world with
animals running everywhere and trying to
make them survive in this environment
it's very odd and to the movies credit
it knows that and tries to have fun with
it but a lot the jokes it tries to throw
at us are really confused for example
there's a scene where you see a dog
mowing the lawn with his neighbor who's
a sheep and literally uses the Sheep to
cut the lawn
there's an idea for a joke there it's
just not fully realized yet maybe if the
dog was using his lawnmower it broke
down and then he asked his neighbor for
help that would be completing the joke
at least giving the world some realm of
existing but then there's weird things
like they'll suddenly cut to a real clip
of Indiana Jones it's like they're
watching a human being do they know what
human beings are in this world I might
be thinking too hard about it except
that they just keep throwing confusing
jokes like this at us there's another
weird joke where the fish pulls a bunch
of cards and pages out of the magazine
and builds a giant building out of it
and acts like he's King Kong why I just
straight up don't even get this one the
humor is fast and tries to throw every
opportunity at a joke a chem but I
really don't know if they thought them
through before they actually decide to
put them in but okay if jokes are bad
that's one thing how are the characters
strangely enough I really find myself
hating most of them I mean the loser
gang is just sorry your typical loser
gang nothing really new but the rest of
the town and especially the father are
just too damn mean in this film I know
that sounds weird because we come from
environments like the Simpsons in South
Park where they have all sorts of mean
people do stupid things but something
about this world seems so constantly
heart and just never giving a break to
the main character except when he does
something that indulges their selfish
egos like when a ball game the dad
especially I think is really despicably
unlikable the stuff he says to this kid
is not only bad but God I think it would
scar most kids it's not just lack of
support it's trying as hard as he can to
have nothing to do with his child and
yeah I know he's supposed to learn his
lesson in the end and he obviously does
but you're supposed to kind of want this
guy to get back together with his son
and in the end I really don't I thought
he was just horrible I think the only
thing I really remembered sticking out
in this film is the design of the alien
which I have to admit I just never saw
an alien design like this before
most aliens look the same but these
designs are pretty damn original so I'll
give it that as for the rest of it not
only do I think it's not very funny but
I don't think it's very developed I
don't think it's very focused in the
jokes and like I said before it's just
kind of
being spirited I know some people show
it to their kids and I don't know if I'd
say it's so bad like it would scar kids
or anything but I definitely wouldn't
let my kids see it I mean I went boycott
or anything but at the same time I
probably tried to create as much
distance from it as well the father does
with his son I'm sure the film had good
intentions and that it wanted to get
across some good messages but in the end
it's just too unpleasant for me I know
there's definitely some people out there
that like it but for me I will give it a
pass
you